je souhaitais bonsoir bonsoir ans j'ai
demandé de venir que vous êtes intéressé
par l'histoire sainte la preuve vous
avez fait les dix commandements
vous avez fait un livre avec andré
chouraqui dont on a parlé la dernière
fois que vous étiez ici et vous êtes
sensible à l'antisémitisme puisque vous
venez de réaliser pour envoyé spécial
un documentaire voilà alors le premier
point de la polémique sur la passion du
christ et l'antisémitisme donc et même
avant sa sortie aux usa le film a été
mis en cause par la licra local
l'anti-defamation league du rabbin
foxman et le producteur de miramax
harvey weinstein a appelé ses associés
français tfm pour leur demander de ne
pas distribuer le film dans notre pays
alors il ya un certain nombre d'exemples
je pense qu'il faut être pratique je
pense qu'on va les prendre les uns après
les autres et voir si c'est des points
qui démontrerait ou qui démontre
l'antisémitisme du film alors par
exemple ponce pilate sympa dire que
ponce pilate
c'est vrai que dans le film il donne
l'impression finalement de laisser les
juifs crucifié jésus est lui en fait il
n'a pas tellement envie de le faire sa
femme
encore moins que lui et c'est vrai que
c'est une version un petit peu
différente de ce qu'on a l'habitude de
lire ou de d'entendre ça non ponce
pilate est exactement comme tous les
autres films que j'ai faits sur jésus
ambigu hommes politiques calculateur
opportuniste et à la fin et décide pour
des raisons politiques
même s'il n'avait pas très envie de le
tuer c'est encore pire
1 uma rien fait il a l'air gentil
flageller le et crucifié le moment loin
de moi l'idée de 200 sio de condamner un
film c'est la responsabilité d'un auteur
quand il fait un film c'est sa vision
des choses et on peut la respecter ce
qu'on peut faire ensuite c'est porter un
jugement - j'ai vu le film c'est vrai
que c'est un film sectaire violent
raciste antisémite je le pense
profondément
je pense par exemple que non parce que
sinon ça sert prenons pilates pour
commencer de ponce pilate dans le film
est un humaniste et son humanité sa
réflexion sur la mort de jésus
fait peser tout le poids de la
condamnation à la crucifixion sur le
peuple juif et les rabbins qui sont là
hurler pour demander la crucifixion
ça c'est ponce pilate et une deuxième
chose moi que j'ai trouvé dans le film
très antisémites ou anti judaïque dix
ans c'est quand les grands prêtres paye
judas pour avoir trahi le christ il
jette les 32 ni à la figure les jette
une bourse et la bourse tombe par terre
ce qui n'est pas dans les évangiles il a
ce moment la juda semé a ramassé par
terre comme ça alors vous trouvez pas
que c'est un cliché un peu antisémite ça
pas du tout vous savez là attendez dont
jésus de nazareth il y avait la même
chose
il n'a pas été traité d'être antisémite
et puis je voudrais revenir il ya 2000
ans cinq ou six rabbins avait décidé de
condamner un autre à main jésus est un
rabbin ouais il a grandi dans la
grandeur de la religion juive
il a eu un désaccord à l'époque et 2000
ans avec des gens qui étaient plus
conservateur que lui je ne vois pas en
quoi le peuple juif de l'image en mai je
suis la commande est pas que cette image
de judas qui ramassent leurs parterres
comme ça c'est un gros cliché antisémite
quand même non mais c'est du cinéma
ouais c'est l'oeuvre d'un metteur en
scène n'a pas fait un film on a le droit
d'en on a droit de porter un jugement
mais naturellement elie chouraqui a dit
que tout le monde a le droit de passer
en jugement
il ya déjà plus de cinq cent mille
français quand vu le film
laissons les juger oui les us et
d'ailleurs il ya eu un sondage aux états
unis pardonnez-moi 60 millions de
personnes ont vu le film va se jouer
il ya eu un sondage organisé par le
congrès juif mondial pouvoir si on était
plus antisémite
avant ou après avoir vu le film est ce
qu'on les plus ou moins à la grande
surprise on l'est moins et vous savez
pourquoi pas s'ils ont découvert que
jésus était un rabbin et qu'il était
juif et que la plupart des chrétiens ne
le savent pas je sais et je suis sûr que
parmi les jeunes en france ça serait la
même chose
cette scène de judas qui ramasse les
deniers des données encore une fois
et on peut avoir mille vision de ce film
une vision objective des faits objectifs
tarak et vous êtes un homme trop
intelligent je pense pour manquer à ce
point d'objectivité que vous défendiez
un film que vous distribuez et pour
lequel vous avez de l'estiment permettez
un syndic elle vous avez de l'estivé je
comprends parfaitement
c'est vrai que dans ce film à différents
moments - j'ai eu les chaussettes me
glisser le long des mollets c'est quand
j'ai vu jude a essayé de ramasser
l'argent quand j'ai vu les rabbins lancé
des pierres quand j'ai vu mon spi lattes
humanise je me suis dit mais on est dans
une autre dimension
c'est dire que non on est on est dans
une vision qui est une vision
manichéenne et sectaires autre exemple
vous autres les entendez votre exemple
on est dans la vision des quatre
évangiles 90
le vatican n'a pas condamné le film et
pardonnez moi je vous corrige vous avez
dit qu abraham foxman a dit que le film
était antisémite
c'est faux et abraham foxman a dit que
le film n'était pas antisémite mais qui
pouvait sur des esprits simples
peut-être éveillé de l'antisémitisme
attention autre exemple tarak autre
exemple le diable il ya s'attend dans ce
film où il est toujours du côté des
juifs c'est à dire à chaque fois marqué
pour sa journée par une femme
oui ce qui est déjà très curieux d'avoir
d'ajouter à la mi une forme de misogynie
c'est la première fois a soudain
pourquoi est-ce que tout à coup sortant
des évangiles le diable serait une femme
mais attendez vous venez de dire tout à
l'heure c'est une oeuvre d'un metteur en
scène et calais personnel vous êtes
réalisateur mais absolument pas fait des
heures personnel para maintenant refaire
le film
pourquoi ben je vais vous êtes habitants
est toujours du côté des juifs il
importe d'abord ils sont à fond derrière
mais d'abord ils sont tous juifs
pardonnez moi tout le monde est juif
dans le film sauf les romains dont vous
voulez vous qu'ils passent ou parmi les
romains ou parmi les juifs tarak et que
je dise le fond de ma pensée mais
j'espère je pense que ce film reprend
tout un tas de clichés antisémites ou
plutôt anti judaïque qui avait été
abolie à l'époque devant tic en deux par
jean xxiii en 1965 le crime de déicide
le pape à l'époque a dit il n'est pas
question de considérer des juifs comme
les déicide le pape jean paul ii
quelques années après et est allé dans
une synagogue à rome pour demander
pardon pour faire repentance et j'ai
l'impression que ce film finalement nous
ramène avant 25 ans de qu'il annule 50
ans d'efforts de réconciliation
j'ai plus on reproche que je lui fais
finalement 50 ans d'efforts de
réconciliation entre les juifs et des
chrétiens et vous n'avez pas vu dans le
film l'amour
si le pardon la compassion si la grâce
la spiritualité
s'ils n'ont pas que tu es un dieu ils
ont tué un homme
pardonnez-moi jésus ici il n'y a pas eu
d incident
ils ont tué un homme c'est après qu'on a
dit que c'était un dieu mais à l'époque
c'était un homme et si c'était un dieu
il serait pas mort il se serait sauvé
même lui fait appel à dieu pour le
sauver donc
excusez moi bien sûr je lis je respecte
votre opinion mais mel gibson a dit je
reconnais vatican 2 et le justement il
ne reconnaît pas à mon avis le problème
de mel gibson c'est qu'ils les
intégristes comme monseigneur lefebvre
était et est intégriste d'ailleurs jeu
c'est à dire qu'il est d'avant vatican 2
c'est à dire que pour lui finalement il
en est resté à l'appréciation d'avant
c'est à dire les juifs sont un peuple
déicide et on doit pas se réconcilier
alors que le pas par bien reconnu jean
paul ii la filiation qui avait entre eux
la religion juive et la religion
catholique mais j'ai l'intention les
oppose de nouveau généré sur vous et des
efforts qui ont été faits depuis 50 ans
sont annihilés par ce film c'est le gros
reproche que je n'y fait après j'ai
plein de compliments à lui faire alors
ni vous ni moi nous représentons le
vatican ouais si ce que vous dites est
vrai vous ne pensez pas que le vatican
après vatican ii avec le poids que porte
vatican sur le conflit entre les juifs
et les chrétiens comme vous avez dit
qu'ils ont voulu apaiser tout ça pour
effet une déclaration de dénonciation du
film le vatican non seulement a soutenu
le film mais en italie le vatican a
obtenu qui n'y aucune interdiction
je veux juste dire une chose on on
attaque on est haut à la genèse d'un
siècle qui risque d'être extrêmement
tourmente malraux lundi sera un siècle
de religion ça ne sera pas la
responsabilité de certains ados vous
dont moi dont thierry dans des zones qui
sont des zones de rapport avec le public
est aujourd'hui non pas de faire partie
de ceux qui vont attiser les haines
entre les communautés mais de faire
partie de ceux au contraire qu'ils vont
rappeler que les communautés et surtout
les trois religions du livre puisqu'il
ya un chrétien et juif est un musulman
ici les trois religions du livre sont
implantés dans la même terre et sont les
mêmes et ont le même dieu je pense qu'il
ya danger
surtout quand on est un homme comme vous
allez du côté de ceux qui peuvent être
sectaire
alors d'abord mon pointage que dit elie
chouraqui je partage également ses idées
sur les religions et nous avons le
moindre point de vue puisqu'il vient lui
c'est un juif arabe et moi je suis un
arabe juives crif hier alors vous savez
sur ceux des bas salaires stérile mais
c'est la vérité je ne suis pas d'accord
sur l'interprétation du film et je ne
suis pas d'accord qu'il n'y a pas des
scènes d'amour y a huit flash back dans
le film on voit jésus pardonner parler
d'amour et dire des mais c est déjà les
alors j'allais vous le dire et je le dis
voilà ce qu'on n'a pas dit au sujet de
ce film à mon sens on a dit plein de
choses ce qu'on n'a pas dit c'est
qu'au-delà de son anti judaïsme dix ans
voire antisémitisme il a porté le
message du christ et ça je suis d'accord
ça n'a pas été dit par les journalistes
à dire qu'il ya tout un tas de flashback
où jésus dit aimez vous les uns les
autres qui sont grands messages à un
moment il vit vous
mais vos proches vous détestez vos
ennemis c'est facile d'aimer ses proches
puisqu'ils vous à nous ce qui est
difficile c'est d'aimer ses ennemis et
de pardonner à ses ennemis donc ça c'est
très positif ça c'est ce que je trouve
de plus positif dans le film et je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas dit sarah que
je suis un passionné de jésus je trouve
que c'est le l'inde est l'un des fils
préféré de dieu si ça n'est pas son fils
en tout cas pour moi c'est l'un des fils
préféré de dieu je trouve que cette
l'image de cet homme qui a donné son
corps et sa souffrance pour l'humanité
est une des images les plus belles de
l'histoire de l'humanité
pourquoi en avoir fait cette espèce de
chose
monstrueusement violente peut-être parce
que l' empire romain était violent
justement l'ambassade deuxième reproche
qui a été fait au film le premier c'est
l'antisémitisme
on en a parlé le deuxième c'est la
violence les gens étaient choqués par
cette espèce de péplum gore jésus est
passé à tabac dès son arrestation
ce qui n'est pas le cas face qui est pas
en tous les cas les écritures safran saf
et de lille dans les évangiles ça dure
20 minutes à l'écran mais je viens de la
vision vous avez reconnu pour ses la
vision d'un metteur en scène c'est vrai
d'accord les flèches génération mais les
flagellations qui dure 20 minutes
alors je peux vous corriger oui les
plans nous voyons jésus flageller et sur
la croix dure huit minutes la
crucifixion deux minutes et demie la
flagellation cinq et demi
ensuite il ya les plans sur les romains
sur les sur le sang sur le public mais
sur lui 8 minutes et vous connaissez la
puissance de l'image vous savez ce
qu'elle peut signifier 7e
on a l'impression que ce pauvre homme
entreprenant pendant deux heures en
prend mais au delà de ce qu'un homme
peut subir mais d'aborder l'art est il
exactement ce qu'il a subi
on décrit dans le prophète isaïe qu'il
était comme un agneau à l'abattoir et
qu'il était tellement d'y figurer par la
violence des romains et vous croyez que
les romains au niveau de la flagellation
d'un crucifix gâteau ils s'amusaient
mais les romains à l'époque avant
jésus-christ et jeter les bébés dans les
poubelles
alors pourquoi maintenant taravella mars
course-là violent et score sur la
violence et que les romains
je parle des reproches qui ont été faits
au film premier reproche l'antisémitisme
deuxième reproche la violence troisième
reproche parce que tu troisième reproche
3e reçoit les critiques mais c'est
encore là alors là ça devient
parfaitement subjective si les critiques
des cinéphiles qui disent que c'est pas
un bon film mais ça je me permettrais
pas de juger parce que c'est là le
moteur mais alors jean-pierre bouquet de
signer à c'est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un bon film ce plan cinéphilique
ou non moi je trouve que me lier ça est
un merveilleux metteur en scène je
trouve que c'est un problème du film
c'est qu'il arrive à montrer des choses
avec une force incroyable c'est un bon
metteur en scène c'est tout le danger
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que j'aurais
tellement aimé qu'il met son talent au
service non pas de ce que lui enseigner
son père c'est à dire ceux son père qui
est un révisionniste qui a fait des
déclarations sur son père a dit
alexandre y attendait trop bien on juge
le film où le pen j'en ai je ne sont pas
des procès non mais c'est très
intéressant quand je dis pas qu'il faut
faire un procès au fisc dit que vatican
ii
c'était un complot maçonnique financé
par les juifs et mais c'est un film
d'avant vatican ii les de mel gibson a
répondu en direct à la télévision
américaine sur ce point je reconnais
vatican ii il s'est dissocié de son père
dans son film s'il reconnaît vatican ii
c'est ça que je comprends parlement vous
allez demander au vatican
vous allez aller au vatican donc posé la
question moi j'y suis allé et ils ont
reconnu le film et ils ne l'ont pas
dénoncé
donc ce plan cinéphilie que vous en
pensez quoi non je répète c'est un homme
qui a un qui a du talent les images qui
sont très belle dans le film le plus
beau plan que j'ai vu dans le film c'est
le plan ou marie embrasse les pieds de
son fils parce que c'est un plan qui m'a
réconcilié avec pendant un instant avec
mel gibson si je me suis dit voilà cet
homme comprend l'amour filial donc s'il
comprend l'amour entre une une main et
sont enfin il peut comprendre l'amour
entre un homme jésus est et le reste de
l'humanité entre l'humanité
et dieu mais j'ai eu tellement j'ai
attendu deux heures ce plan avant qu'il
n'arrive donc quand il est arrivé
effectivement j'ai été soulagé alors
d'abord la chose la plus importante
c'est la fin du film
c'est le pardon de jésus c'est le pardon
pour ses ennemis
c'est ce qu'ils prient pour plusieurs de
pardonner à ses aînés de rabat qui
commencent à comprendre que peut-être
c'est un homme pieux qui est sûre cette
croix y prie pour lui je vais rejoindre
elie chouraqui
moi j'ai pris ce film non pas pour
ouvrir les plaies entre les communautés
au contraire la violence de ce film vous
d'y arrêter la violence je suis pas un
violence de ce film démontre que
l'intégrisme que l'intolérance que
l'aveuglément des foules que
l'interprétation d'un homme politique
pilates ou de quelques rabbins contre un
autre rabbin
car jésus était arabe un peu a mené à la
mort un homme innocent dans une cruauté
insupportable
et qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est l'islam qui est
intolérante et qui tuent au nom d'un soi
disant livre interprétée par certains
barbu qui se disent connaître mieux
l'islam
il y à des intégristes religieux
catholiques vouloir vous en avait parlé
il y a des rabbins intégristes-- l'icône
est bien là et moi aussi
son message les dix commandements ça
c'est une oeuvre où nous avons vu les
juifs les arabes les chrétiens je ne
suis pas sûr que la violence de ce film
soit négatif au contraire elle réveille
les consciences vous savez pourquoi le
jour ce film est sorti on a vu à haïti
on a vu madrid on est donc touché par
une réalité et on ne souffre que pour
nos morts
eh bien peut-être que ça va donner envie
aux gens de réfléchir que depuis deux
mille ans les religions sont manipulés
les rues gili gens sont mal interprétés
et qu'avec cette intolérance
on tue on torture qui a du sens mais
qu'est ce que voulez qu'il y ait dans
une crucifixion
c'est ce qu'a dit mel gibson il a choisi
sa la croix que vous avez dans vos
églises
un peu de sang ici est un peu de sang
ici regardez l'horreur que c'était et
regardez ce que faisait les romains et
c'est les romains qui le font et j'ai
fait appel aux musulmans de france
ne tombez pas dans l'erreur
d'antisémitisme car celui qui est
antisémite et anti arabes
les arabes et les juifs sont les fils
d'abraham j'ai fait la bible il a fait
les dix commandements il sait de quoi je
parle
moi je suis pour que des films réveille
les communautés c'est peut-être un peu
trop réveiller et ben jamais assez trop
sauf que gibson la chance d'avoir un
distributeur comme ça parce que un homme
qui défendent le film d'un metteur en
scène comme nom générique leno médiation
que j'ai eus je joue vivent avec les
juifs catholiques je l'étais à l'école
qu'intelligent les jeux ce soit je ne
peux pas croire je vous connais que vous
n'ayez pas en ait un regard objectif sur
ce film que vous n'ayez pas un moment
donné tremblay en vous disant il est
allé trop loin et ce film ne reflète pas
ce qu'ils devraient refléter je ne le
crois pas maintenant je vais vous dire
comment j'ai réagi quand j'ai vu le film
d'abord j'étais très ému parce que j'ai
vu des vieux rabbin qui ont rien compris
à jésus comme des vieux moufti qui
condamne rouchdi comme des vieux prêtre
qui condamne des jeunes prêtres
j'ai vu des gens parce qu'il faut qu'une
barbe et qui pensent qu'ils ont la robe
qu'ils ont le message de dieu
le message de dieu c'est l'amour la
compassion la fraternité dans les trois
religions et des individus illuminés
dans le monde se permet de tuer au nom
de ces religions et ben ces rabbins à
l'époque on condamner jésus
spirituellement pas physiquement et ça
dans la bible c'est vrai vous le savez
et lee vous savez qu'il voulait s'en
débarrasser
et vous savez qu'ils auraient à pilate
donc est ce qu elle s'écrira maman
et le résultat de ce que ces rabbins on
veut lui éliminé sera main qui leur a
dit en deux mots vous êtes des vieux
vous êtes vous avez rien compris
voilà ce qu'a dit le bon dieu mais c'est
rabat raconte a mené pratiquement 2001
de honte un monde interne et les
croisades c'est tout ce message là toute
cette structure mentale là à monter les
communautés les unes contre les autres
et je pense que tu y réalisons
qu'ardisson le disais la vérité quand il
a dit ce ce film est un film d'avant
vatican
moi je pense qu'on arrive rnt pour
conclure je dis encore une fois que ce
qu'on n'a pas dit sur le film et ça je
le dis c'est que ce film contient le
message d'amour du christ et ne serait
ce que pour ça il faut aller le voir je
serais ce que pour juger d'abord te dire
juste une dernière chose j'aurais juste
que les jeunes gens surtout les jeunes
gens qui vont aller voir ce film se
rappelle encore que c'est la vision d'un
metteur en scène que c'est sa façon de
voir les choses que cet homme est
particulier qu'il a une histoire
particulière et qu'il faut connaître son
histoire pour comprendre ce qu'il a fait
2-2 ce parcours de jésus et je voudrais
faire appel aux millions de personnes
qui voient l'émission de thierry
ardisson
surtout ne pensez pas que les quelques
rabbins qui il ya deux mille ans on
condamner jésus sont les juifs
d'aujourd'hui comme les italiens
aujourd'hui ne sont pas les capots
romains qui ont flageller crucifié jésus
donc nous ne transmettons pas de père en
fils les horreurs du passé
est-ce que les turcs d'aujourd'hui sont
les turcs du génocide arménien et je
pourrais continuer comme ça sans
m'arrêter
bragdon qui comme ça nous avait yeux
mais non c'est la vie c'est vrai que
j'aurais aimé voir ce que vous dites
dans le film allez-y pour vous faire
votre avis et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de finale andy tu es abonné vous
mettez un pouce bleus